on va parler maintenant un peu de total
et des jeux olympiques alors ça ne fait
pas bon ménage pour la maire de paris
c'est donc anne hidalgo qui a lancé les
hostilités en déclarant que total était
persona non grata en 2024 au nom de
l'urgence environnementale
emmanuel macron lui a répondu ce
week-end regarder total doit s'engager
dans une politique de transition
énergétique
c'est ça ce qu'il faut faire il faut les
aider à cela et si total peut mettre de
l'argent pour financer aider à financer
des jeux verts si total peut mettre de
l'argent pour aider à financer la
transition c'est une bonne chose
et voici maintenant les arguments côté
mairie de paris c'est emmanuelle
grégoire premier adjoint qui veut pas
dire on veut des jeux verts mais on fait
avec total
c'est pas cohérent ça aurait été
reproché au comité d'organisation est
encore une fois l'idée ceni d'ostraciser
total qui est un grand acteur industriel
mais dont il faut que les change de
modèle parce que son modèle polluent et
tuent les gens
en faisant de la pollution et pour cela
il y a des moyens de l'accompagner de
façon positive autrement que par le
sponsoring des jeux olympiques alors
cohérent ou pas non mais c'est amusant
parce que vous savez que total a donné
100 millions à notre-dame par exemple
alors je ne sais pas accepter ça pose
pas de problème à notre pari on va de
même si c'est l'état mais c'est quand
même la mairie de paris donc son million
pour notre problème est alors mise de
l'autre côté moi je trouve ça assez
juste en effet en vue des jeux verts pas
totale mais à ce moment là un des
sponsors du cio et coca cola on sait que
l'obésité c'est un drame dans le monde
entier dont il faut pas de coca cola non
plus je voyais à toyota au cylindre
des halles attention attention parce que
quand tu es truffaut jardinerie oui y'a
un moment j'ai avec total en complément
des pesticides
au total le problème c'est que comme on
voit irwin en effet en matière d'huile
de palme ils ont réouvert en effet à une
raffinerie à côté de marseille là l'état
ne dit rien et d'un coup là il vient à
son secours quand il n'est plus aux jeux
olympiques dont on ne sait pas ce qu'il
défend fait le gouvernement
véritablement est ce que c'est les
efforts de total matière d'environnement
où c'est le fait qu'une grande
entreprise française ne pourrait pas se
faire de la publicité
lors du plus grand événement sportif du
monde c'est ça qui est un peu compliqué
non c'est aussi l'idée de donner des
leçons de morale
effectivement une grande entreprise
française qui n'est pas que cet aspect
oui qui pollue mais oui il faut appeler
dernier etc
non mes moyens il ya quelque chose qui
me fait plutôt sourire c'est escape a
déjà un oxymore avec jeux olympiques et
vert c'est à dire que organiser des jeux
olympiques en soi est ce que c'est pas
une démarche totalement anti et du bilan
carbone des livres car l'an dernier
j'aimerais me reconnaître ce que c'est
le bétonnage et tous les travaux tout on
n'est pas en train de construire des
espaces verts là pour les jeux
olympiques donc voila moi ça me fait
sourire parce que franchement est
l'exemple de jean mathieu sur coca cola
sur avions des millions de touristes du
monde entier de viande à des millions de
vols de toutes façons il s'y
retrouveront total c'est pas un souci
mais non c'est trop c'est trop quoi
puiser c'est pas tellement loin du sujet
précédent c'est quand même une fois de
plus des limitations des interdits
dérogeait on peut pas dire total tu es
avoir des stations total dans paris
excusez moi mais moi je demain je vais
faire le plein de mons coût très élevé à
total var des invalides enfin la place
des halles sur l'esplanade des invalides
et là on vient de me dire ballon on peut
pas prendre totale puisque le total tube
mercy total tu comment est ce que je
peux avoir le droit d'aller me fournir
chez un assassin non ça va pas de sous
[Rires]
anne hidalgo
ça nous ramène aussi au sujet d' encore
avant qu'ils aient la mairie de paris
qu'est ce que c'est ça aussi parce que
c'est les écologistes pour les élections
pour faire plaisir à sa maîtresse avait
démoli les uns et les autres
donc non mais ça risque de tourner court
son nom parce qu'il ya plein de gens
notamment des lecteurs parisiens qui
sont faits c'est bien les courageuses et
tout ça et puis on que bon élan total ne
veut pas non plus de bad buzz est passé
un mois sur les réseaux sociaux mais
parce qu'ils ont à faire cirer de la
serbie au total voilà je constate c'est
que ça lui aussi un peu l'accent aussi
sur les mécènes c'est dire qu'il de
temps en temps faire attention il ya eu
la semaine dernière un manifestant n'a
rien à voir une manifestation propos
louvre de gens qui critiquaient le fait
qu'il ya une aide du louvre aujourd'hui
qui s'occupe des antiquités du proche
orient qui est sponsorisé par un des
plus grands laboratoires américains qui
en pleine crise d'opioïdes vous savez il
ya un drame aux états unis sanitaires
dont il a fait une chronique voilà tout
à fait et donc aujourd'hui c'est que on
fait plus à 10h50 pas de la cca c'est
assez intéressant de voir aujourd'hui à
quel point les mécènes aussi ont fait
pas avancer pas attention aujourd'hui on
est dans un monde où on regarde
davantage ce qui peut se passer
et c'est vrai que total quoi qu'on en
dise même si ça fournit de l'emploi même
si c'est important oripeaux lui détruit
aussi une partie est donc en
contradiction
oui ça oui mais c'est en contradiction
avec la démarche aujourd'hui verte que
normalement mardi le patron n'a pas
interné la voiture n'a pas interdit
l'avion faut pas exagérer et par
ailleurs total comme plein d'autres
états comme les constructeurs mille sont
en train de réfléchir au modèle d'apple
c'est son domaine et enrichissent venait
d'apparaître
maintenant non
biocarburants les éoliennes de racheter
la boîte américaine qui fait des trucs
solaire enfin il met des milliards et
des milliards 7 mai eux et d'autres je
ne fais pas la pub de total mais ils ont
ils résidaient sur un modèle économique
et le temps de passer au prochain ils
investissent des milliards et devenir
donc si on arrête total on arrêtera
aussi le nucléaire le l'éolienne le la
biomasse enfin il faut plein plein de
trucs le soleil et en même temps c'est
peut-être aussi ya aussi la marque par
s'endormir il faut quand même qu'on soit
cohérent si c'est leur activité n'est
pas interdite
si elle produit de la pâte avec
notamment parce qu'elle produit de
l'emploi parce qu'elle produit de la
valeur et c'est utile à ce moment là
pourquoi diable et que si j'ai
l'occasion moi de les faire être mécène
de sciences po et qui nous permettent de
financer des chaires d'ailleurs pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique est bien très bien prenons
l'engagement on prendrait marlboro à ce
moment mais je prendrai un homme
commence bien et ça me prenait encore
n'est pas encore interdit de jeter les
fonctions sur le sponsoring regarder des
choses comme marlboro
c'est comme ça aujourd'hui lors exemple
quelqu'un d'aussi important dossier
intelligence et les médias mais elle
fume ça donne une image valorisante à
cigarette c'est cela qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il ya un moment pourquoi son
blaze sont un peu bas on pense à tous
ceux qui veulent donner de l'argent sauf
si évidemment ils sont en train de
fabriquer du zyklon b pour exterminer
des gens donc il ya des limites
si l'on a visit lobé mais je l'amène
paris prenez l'exemple de lafarge en
disant on
interdite au feu pas totalement comme on
ne veut pas non plus faire d'affaires
accepté de l'argent de lafarge prétexte
oui en revanche lafarge précise pour les
activités supposées de lafarge en série
au moment de deuil dans les disques j'en
pensais je trouve que tant que les
activités des entreprises en question ne
sont pas illégales je vois pas pourquoi
on ne la reprendrais pas de l'argent au
contraire ça va être vu leurs bénéfices
et ça aide aux contributions des
intérêts publics
alors nos internautes comprenez vous que
la mairie de paris refuse total comme
sponsor non à 66%
nicole dit si on voulait vraiment éviter
la pollution il suffisait de ne pas
faire les jeux wii hidalgo cherche les
voix des écolos parisien pour l'année
prochaine
ces deux enjeux effectivement et bah
écoutez on va s'arrêter sur ces grandes
paroles définitives sur total et le
reste